let's go ahead and go live
okay for people joining this live stream
we are
in a period of intense design reviews
for version 12.3
and uh right now we are about to look at
uh geography okay
so the big thing is
having um vector
oops vector
rendering okay what does that mean
oh great what does that mean
let's see so um
so so this is something that uh is
related to
probably the x kernel and and we are
changing this this thing so
the um the main topic
right now is to convert sorry to fix
everything that
will make uh that is preventing to make
vector the default uh result in
geographics
and so what we wanted to show here and i
can do two things either i send you
another notebook with these evaluated
or i share myself and show the results
um can you send me another notebook yes
i do that you know in a moment
uh francisco can you explain what's
going on here actually you know what why
don't you share are you ready to share
i i'm totally ready yes okay okay go
ahead go
you go and share yep
um okay so
yes so these uh are the new labels that
we are making now
to follow the uh lines
and um how does it decide where to put a
label relative to
the extent of a street yes so what we
have
initially is the line say the street and
the
the text and what we do here is simply
to find
a place of the street which is flat
enough
and then take the center and distribute
the letters the individual letters
these are individual text objects around
that point
and so hold on hold on let me understand
because one of these streets
how many how many into how many pieces
is the street typically shattered
uh that depends on the data and the data
we have actually
breaks the lines in too many pieces
that's for example in a case like this
it may be happening that the
the straight that the street is broken
here and so
that's why it's not selecting the right
and then there is the selection of the
piece of the street that is
better and then there is also the
collision algorithm so
once we place a label we cannot place
another one that will collide with it or
a distance there is a
safety distance around it okay and what
about that label down there on the on
the green
it's just that thing yeah yes so this
is following this line but uh there is
no
instruction to avoid the line okay
yeah so this is following a line that is
centered on the streets
actually these streets i mean this is
not the street these are the borders of
these
yellowish lines yellow is area sorry
so just i see so then there yeah and
these are also labels so we cannot let
the arrows collide with the with the
strings
right but so what are we doing with
respect to these fragmented streets so
to speak
uh there is nothing we can do but
well we have this algorithm that also
tries to nurture cisco you're hard to
hear
yeah sorry
okay
well let me know when you're you see it
better
not really no you sound like you're in a
cave but we can hear you go ahead
okay
we have a step where we try to to merge
all the lines that share the same
name and the same features so
so there is a step trying to do that
before
placing all these names but presumably
we do that level of the tile generation
no not yet because we are not
controlling that process yet okay but we
will do that right because we don't we
want to be doing the merging
at the time when we're doing rendering
right i mean the rendering needs to be
as efficient as possible
okay so the so this comes in tiles so
what we do
is across the boundaries of the tiles we
do
uh join things in in real time because
the
the the boundaries are very well defined
and that's a fast process
okay so for example we have polygons but
merging polygons is important because
when we do projections etc
we don't want this intermediate these
flat lines
to to give the impression that we have
two different things there
but within that tile we just follow what
the
with the data okay question i mean as as
we zoom
we're going to gain and lose labels
correct yes indeed
and in dynamic geographics you'll see
that happening yes yes
exactly okay great yeah so these so we
have three examples here
this is a small example of a map so this
is a medium example in which you have
many
i mean more labels and it's easier to
see how the
uh they follow the roads it looks quite
nice yeah it does
yeah and we have a larger example here
which is yeah okay it looks really nice
and we chose this city because it has
that the coast and the mountains
and everything makes the appearance of
of
of curved for example this is quite
impressive
and you see how here is being able to
select the
the flattest area uh part of the car
oh the mountain road exactly cool hey
for my general knowledge what is the
thing is that a lake that monaco is on
uh this is the mediterranean yeah
mediterranean
oh okay it's down okay i'm very confused
by where all this is just next to nice
oh okay next door basically
an hour okay
right and yeah so so this works well but
i mean
these at the moment we are fighting time
here because
uh this involves about a thousand
individual text objects
and so at the very end there is the
preparation and rendering so
so that adds about a second
so we are now uh yeah improving
that that time so what takes the time
there i mean presumably we can cache
those
objects at when we're doing final
rendering well go ahead i don't know
what so there are two parts here one
is the uh what we were explaining before
the collision algorithm
the computation of the box of each
letter part of that can be cached etc
and then there is the fact that at the
very end we give a thousand text objects
to graphics
and graphics have a okay so that's up to
brett
and then the question is how does that
get faster that rendering process
is brett here yes
and um
that is what we've been looking at and
um
you know how how to get it down from you
know a thousand to a smaller number by
doing
multi forms and i think i mean
ultimately i'm guessing we're gonna need
a a text path okay so that
that you don't send them individually
but there is a notion of curved text
as a primitive yes i think you should
talk to the front-end team about that
yeah maybe someone like lutsu could work
on that go ahead
i was gonna say i checked you know a
couple weeks ago after you know we had
our last meeting about this
and it isn't the case
that you know that's i mean that's not a
built-in thing and
we know different drawing layers we use
which but i know so we will have to ask
people
yep i think this is the sort of thing
that
is more important in geo than in other
areas like dynamic geographics or
geolagering
so so it's it's something that will
appear first in geo
and then eventually will extend to
more generations yeah we'll have other
places where you know
we could certainly make use of that
um so jose i don't remember the exact
details or where we're
at on this so
how much of that computation is image
size dependent
or are we scaling
right so like you have image size goes
to a thousand there and if
it was 500 instead yeah we can check
i mean this will be it will produce less
labels so it will be
a bit faster a bit faster
okay that was quite fast that was quite
fast okay
go to image size 1500
1500
by the way for users
who resize a graphic okay
it's still not a particularly dense area
yeah um it has quite quite a lot of
villains
well and it also has the zoom level
hard-coded in that input
so oh i see
oh it does probably if i remove this
uh well i could what
would it do monaco has only a point
so this is going to show a very large
area yeah
oh let's see
oh goodness sorry jose
that's new okay
let's show the area first
yeah so this is showing monaco i don't
know what happened there
by the way why are those mountains so so
linear why are we not busying them or
something or does that i mean it's
probably a bad idea to do that but
mountains look over looking worse here
than they usually do
yeah i think i think this is this
combination of using uh non-natural
um right so they they are prepared to be
shown like this
i see the fact that we were showing it
very large
makes it okay so here's a question for
users right
so in the cloud what one's used to is if
you resize the graphic it goes back to
the server
and gets new data right but here we're
not doing that
um you see what i'm saying
and i assume that with non-dynamic
geographics
there's no way i mean that just it is
the graphic is what it is
but i think users have to be told that
so to speak
and i do think that there should be some
kind of
i mean in a luxury world some kind of
um uh attached cell or something i mean
what
there's not a lot you can do right i
mean once the graphic has been generated
it's just a bunch of lines
you don't know where it comes from right
i wonder how we can do this i mean i
wonder whether
at the very least we can have an
informational raft or something
that won't so people don't get totally
confused about oh
you know why is this such a lousy map
you know
i just i just generated a tiny map and
then blew it up
i mean they presumably understand that
from images but i wouldn't count on
you know this is a bit confusing that
you can get different labeling if you go
for a different image size do you get
what i'm saying
[Music]
the question is what can we do about
that
is there any way of of of intercepting
this
this thing and forcing another map
possibly there is we should look at that
i mean
that's you know part of what dynamic
geographics does
is you know when you resize a dynamic
geographic
it isn't you know i know
i know it doesn't scale it's you know i
know extending the
range um the question is is there any
way that we can at least
signal that in um
you know in ordinary geographics yeah
yeah um
have a think about it let's make sure
it's in the user assistance meeting
agenda
okay right so so jose if you go back to
you know where you were zoomed in on
monaco a bit and had
you know labels following roads and
whatever what happens when you manually
resize in that case
oh i see so we had it was this an image
size was that
so this case you mean i resize here yeah
so
you manually take it down to like 500.
yes they they don't rescale the letter
so
they stay the same size so they collide
with each other
that's bad well we have this option of
scaling the letters this method vector
maps scale fonts
true let's see what was the
the name of that for this vector map
[Music]
scale scale font no
font scaling sorry font scale
like that yes true or automatic woodwork
okay so now i do larger for example
yes smaller now go smaller
[Music]
well this is a win i think i don't know
if it's a win is it a win
i mean i think it's more likely that
you're going to you know start out at
the default size and then
drag it larger
in which case you don't necessarily want
things to scale up
yeah well perhaps we won't because
sometimes the letters get too separated
so we start this this small
this looks nice if if we don't do this
the letters get separated
let's try this
that doesn't look bad what's wrong with
that oh they're not getting separated
there
i mean look at the space between each of
the letters
okay so the problem is with kobe roads
yeah
well that seems like the separate ones
are
yeah i see but but the but the pure
labels are looking fine it's just the
roads go on
wrong right the labels look good
yeah because the each letter is is is
preserving its position
in the road yeah i understand there's
not a computation
i mean that means we need a text path
that's the only way to solve that
problem
yeah so you need to talk to people about
that
but in terms of
uh what to do here um
you know look i mean
i do think the scaling thing of letters
is something that would be relevant for
other graphics as well
and i think we might want a general
option saying
you know i don't know text scaling or
something arrow true or false
right and we have a theme that does it
that you know that you know enables
scalable text
yeah for the visualization functions
um
[Music]
let's see
uh but i think i think we want to say
text scaling i mean why don't we just
have a general option
which says text scaling arrow true or
false
that just determines whether it will
generate so it will always generate at
the image size that you ask
for right but then the question is does
it generate
uh text that will be set to be scalable
or not
maybe allow text scaling i don't know
text no text scaling arrow true
false what do you think brett
um
if the front-end team magically
implements it i think it's great um
not it's not for them to do it's for you
to do all it is
is is that's a question of how you
define
when you create text how does it work
please please look at it and talk to the
talk to the founders no i mean
so i mean so the way that it would be
done
is you would change the font size from
whatever it normally i know
to a scaled dynamic thing so that's for
you
it would be just a scaled font size okay
fine
so that's for you to do
right that's for you to do on graphics
generation
that's what i'm saying i'm saying no but
that information comes from the style
sheets
all right i figure out how to do this
okay so i don't know i don't know where
i'm assuming that in the end
i see you're saying the font size comes
from a style sheet all right
well you need to figure out the plumbing
of this because maybe there's a
maybe what happens is that the way it
works is
there's a there's two different styles
in the style sheet one
that's what i was just thinking that you
know and one for other player in a
scaled one on top
right and then that would just work then
what you would do is generate
that style now now
the only difficulty with that is
backward compatibility which
i mean i mean it won't be a problem
backward compatibility wise i don't
think
why not i mean if you generate a style
that's called text scaled
and then somebody tries to render that
graphic in an older version what's going
to happen
it's not going to find any you know
styles it's not going to find a style by
that name and it's going to ignore it
okay it's going to go to the default
which will probably be okay right you
know it'll
it'll fall back to non-scaled texts
right various people are pointing out
here on our live stream that
having an explicit way to change the
label sizes and maps seems like a good
idea
but i'm not you know in other words to
define the scaling
i mean if we called it text scaling and
then we had
automatic none or an actual number 1.7
or something
1.7 would mean scale everything up by a
factor 1.7
[Music]
from whatever you thought it was
supposed to be
am i making sense and that would be a
direct option to geographics or we have
something yes
no direct option to geographics graphics
bunch of well maybe not graphics but
well but eventually graphics
but certainly plot and things like that
so in other words if you say text
scaling arrow two
it'll just make a plot that has bigger
uh you know bigger labels
which i think this is a good idea but
just sitting label style goes to
whatever
i understand i understand i'm just
saying it's a bank switch mechanism for
doing this
i think it's a good idea
i mean i i don't disagree that that's
useful functionality but i mean i think
the
you know the other thing that we've
discussed is
sort of exposing you know generally what
the styling information is
you know i mean
and possibly the text and labels are you
know
special and important enough that they
get their own
thing regardless of yes whatever we come
up with for
because they're the thing wide roads are
um i think we should yes because i think
it's a thing that
affects you know labels
labels are the sort of you know just
like the quality of a video is often
judged by its audio
the quality of these things is often
judged by its labels
by making sense right yeah yeah
we certainly are putting effort into the
labels
okay question the mediterranean
is probably labeled far off somewhere in
a malta or something
but we don't know what it is here
no that's in the data that's
something but i i don't i mean do you
understand my point
yes so so what francisco is saying is
that the data has points where it
recommends to put the labels
and so i mean there could be one here
suddenly
for example exactly the rivers uh rivers
have points where you should put the
name of the river
okay do a map of chicago
okay
i mean mainly because that's the one
where i can remember where the label
that the label shows up
okay this
let's move this to let's leave that
website
actually that's artificially small right
because because of the fact that it
it inherited the graphics size so you
can make it bigger
why won't okay i don't know why it's so
small why is it so small
i mean our default formats are usually
not very large
i mean we can it's just that we are
playing here with with an abnormalist
large sizes so can you increase the geo
range just a bit
yes the the normal size is about 400 i
want to see like michigan
maybe we should increase the default
image size for maps
if they're going to look this beautiful
i think we should
uh to your range what should i put here
right
where's lake michigan labelled yeah
that's what we're trying to find
exactly so let's put uh i don't know
like the loch ness monster or something
i mean it's like 20 miles
20 miles
okay so in other words um
[Laughter]
what's that white so
those are probably boundaries of of
states
right so there we start to get a little
bit of the lake michigan
although it's uh yeah okay um okay 35
i'm just thinking
you know along with null island right
we can have um all the uh you know
uh people in uh you know going on
recreational boats in lake michigan can
try and
you know find where osm has its
l never mind i'm just being silly
somebody could somebody could arrange
it'd be kind of amusing actually
somebody could arrange some recreational
boats to just
spell out lake michigan
never mind so i think these are the
state boundaries
yeah yes that makes sense
okay but so what do you so what you're
saying is
there are default anchor points
for those labels in bodies of water
and presumably also national parks and
who knows what else
other polygonal kinds of things right
and i think like
like michigan there's like a little
curve that runs the length of the lake
down sort of down the middle that is
where it wants to put the label for that
oh boy right right for four legs in
in this data they are lines for the
names
right so look this is a future luxury
why is i see o'hare airport there
why is o'hare airport blank up up up up
up up up
an oasis why is that blank
is that because of a rendering issue
with um
is it this area i think so that should
be o'hare
i mean if you zoom in it might actually
show
individual runways or something no i'm
sure it would but i'm asking
the reason i'm bringing this up is i
don't know where we're getting all the
styling from for these tiles
but it it feels like maybe there are
tile styles missing
like you know a runway style wasn't
added in and that's why there's nothing
there
do you get what i'm saying well
something we are not showing right now
is points of interest so the name at
least for example i think would would
appear if we do that
but airports are not point of interest
they are traffic names so they should be
appearing i see
okay all right so if you go to like
a five mile geo range
around maybe oh yeah just just say
yeah okay yeah okay so let's let's
or airport more or less it probably will
work
try it it has an apostrophe in it
um there we go okay um
five miles
[Music]
are these are these tiles on the cdn yes
they are
so that actual download speed okay
magnificent that is quite detailed
yeah i expected it would be boy the
prevailing winds must be very prevailing
around there
maybe look all the runways are lined up
nice i guess the chicago windy city is
windy only in one direction
everything comes from the west yeah
i i wonder if in the other map it's
blank because it's actually some nine
data
and i'm not sure if we have the airport
lanes at that soon
okay but it's a bit goofy i'm just
pointing that out i mean
there'll be a big tale of these kinds of
issues
right and and we kind of need what is
our qa mechanism
for these maps and noticing stuff like
this
[Music]
that's the silence i mean surely we have
some map nerds
who could be pressed into service
for doing some qa on this i think
we report things as as we find them and
users also report to us things like this
city has
um slightly run your positions right but
i suggest that we identify some actual
map enthusiasts and um
basically what we should do i mean qa
stefan probably needs to um
um uh be involved in this
um and uh you know i don't know how we
validate these things like for instance
you know at the very least we could get
some of these maps and somebody could
just circle
i mean well we could get a bitmap and we
could do bitmap comparisons but
we need to check that things aren't
dropping out and stuff like that
and you know that there isn't goofy
stuff going on
um
there um
okay so comment
uh
okay there's a question okay there's
several questions here that are kind of
interesting
so one question is i mean we also have
geo elevation data but that's a
different base map right
so if you wanted to show bathymetry data
in lake michigan that would be
a different so you would say what would
you say instead of
instead of geo background is vector
marketing which i
can't stand the name of and we need to
come up with a better name we need to
avoid this name marketing is not going
to make it
we need to come up with a geo bright or
some such other thing
uh but we were following the names from
the
themes by the way i know that i know
that but those probably have
names i think they need to be changed i
think it was an amusing idea but i think
we should change it
and i think i don't know what you you
know some name like bright
for example okay so that's the
relief map okay and that can't be
combined with
this can it be combined with a street
map or not and with the vector street
map for example
um not at the moment so that's why we
need a layering mechanism
so for example we should have a way of
say of having some sort of ear layer
and you put inside in this case it would
be uh
at the polygon of the us with geostyling
relief map
and this other case and then we can
click somewhere and
select one or the other right or have a
for example i've seen some places in
which there is a slider
and you say give me percent of one and
sixty percent of the other one
you can you can go from one to the other
that's very nice
right okay that's that's the number of
comments on the live stream i want to
address here ethan is asking can one
tilt the thing to get
3d pictures of of buildings sorry
no i i mean does does osm
have any of the 3d building data in it
yet it has heights yes
yes it does
wow so for example in cities like paris
we have been playing with the eiffel
tower they have
some very rough uh sketch
of the structure of the eiffel tower and
then for the for most of the buildings
they just have a
height so
that's interesting okay well that's
coming attraction
okay the the next um
uh
let's see a font scaling option various
people commenting yes i agree
uh saying nice to provide an explicit
list of entities that you want to label
or not label
yes i mean i think that that's part of
the whole okay
what is the mechanism both for coloring
you know like if i want to highlight
bodies of water for example all those
little
micro lakes which i didn't even know
existed in chicago there
if i wanted to make those all pink for
example how would i do that
so the moment we cannot do that the
style is is
her wire but eventually we want to do
something a thing
like anatomy plot 3d ddas
which is uh specify a a type of object
and then you you say the style you want
for that object can you remind me how
anatomy 3d works
you can say that you want all muscles to
be purple
or you can say that you want you know a
specific
you know your left femur or something to
be
blue the style but but how do you
how do you um uh could you go back up to
the details section there
yes it takes an association
of yeah we have got to change business
and marketing that's stupid
really it doesn't work anymore
brett okay
i'm trying to find one of these cases in
which it says muscle so there is a type
it should be in the documentation so can
we look please what are we looking
for no no in the documentation
in the documentation that's where we
document things okay i'm not
seeing it here so there's a problem with
this documentation brett
okay if it's in the examples it doesn't
count no
scroll back up jose back up
i want to see the top notes yep the top
so
it's an anatomy styling
here i see okay click on anatomy styling
let's see anatomy styling
exactly yeah yeah that's it okay so hold
on
how what classes does it support
do you understand what i'm asking open
the details open the details
so we would have to go to this entity
domain
okay okay so the geo case of this
do we in fact have an entity type
that is a type of geographic object we
should have that
right eventually yes not yet okay i
understand so that will include
you know airports and lakes and rivers
and
uh parks and so on right exactly
and how will that work hierarchically
that is if it's a park it might be a
national park or it might be a state
park
whatever does it deal with the hierarchy
of that
what is in the original data set um you
understand my question
yes right and that's kind of problematic
right now in the sense that uh
for for example buildings don't have the
same data
at all the zooms so so when you zoom out
for example they have less data than
when using in so they include more
tagging
information when you zoom in they have
more oh they have more
tags that's weird well
that's not telling me that's a hack
somebody must have put in there okay
they would i know to make them lighter i
don't know but
but yes we can look into that so to see
what can we
get
um
okay let's see uh someone was
complaining here jarek was complaining
um about uh layout of a river name on
the chicago map can we look at that for
a second
and our river's done the same way as
streets are done
um well rivers are more complicated look
look down by juliet
what's happening to that oh yes this one
yes
so we follow strictly the river so if
there is a part of the river that goes
down
so we are planning to do some better
interpolation here
so right now we are doing some sort of
interpolation of order one
so this needs a smoother interpolation
to have a smoother line but those
what are they called the bendy the you
know the thing that old albert einstein
wrote a paper about once about
about the meandering of rivers where it
eventually bakes off into an oxbow lake
right if that happens a lot i mean
unlike a road
which has a predilection for
straightness a river has a predilection
for meanderingness
right yeah so what do we do about that
and what do we do when it's doubly
connected
for example it goes both ways around an
island in the middle
well if if there are two labels that try
to cross one is going to
eliminate the other one because there is
a there is a collision algorithm
i understand i understand that but i'm
asking the question whereas a road it is
reasonable to look for a straight piece
of a road
for a river there are you know a river
as it
as it evolves so to speak will be
come increasingly meandering and
eventually will break off right and have
have islands in the middle but those are
different lines anyway
for this data okay
i see but nevertheless when it's when
it's meandering
it's going to mess up the letters so
what is
i mean and for example for a street
it is preferential it's preferable
to have the thing follow the street but
for a river
you know labeling it over the island
makes perfect sense that making sense
yes and we have been playing with
different things another problem with
with the reverse is that the the style
is by default italic
so when we are dealing with individual
letters they look like
they are too much rotated and
another thing we have been trying a
method in which
rather than dealing with individual
letters we deal with individual words
so at least within a word everything is
aligned
and that looks a bit better maybe you
can show that in this map for example
uh yeah remind me again of what was what
was the name of there
i mean look i can see the fox river up
to the north there
also looks terrible so this was
francisco vector map
geolabel
i don't remember the name
yes
[Music]
in there in the chat
okay label split method
yes split method
yes and we have mixed here so mixed
meant
sometimes is later sometimes it's worked
right mix will try words for the
italic you know
perhaps without geo here ah yes without
you yes i'm sorry
all right let's take a look at those
rivers okay well that looks a lot better
i mean it's messing up the spacing
between the the words
the dupage river right
is is camelcase there
you see what i'm saying yes yes so i
mean it probably needs to have explicit
somehow the spaces need to be
recognized but other than that it looks
a lot better and i would suggest that
that will be the default for rivers
yeah so this is we okay so
here we have uh we gave up on the rivers
exactly in this particular one so
so this big many the whole uh
thing uh straight it's just an
orientation angle but it's the whole
text
for example here we see this one
okay okay let's let's um let's go on for
some other things sandra is commenting
thought about day night versions of maps
that is a that's a good idea certainly
many gps's do that
but i think that will be for you
okay it's part of a theme sort of thing
yep
so this one looks very much like night
so we can
a little bit like night i mean it's not
really like night
you should but you don't want really
really like nights
i don't know you should look at what
people have done okay well
honestly i think the other one looks a
lot better i we've got work to do on the
default themes here
brad right i mean that default theme
really doesn't look very good i think it
isn't in modern times
it's not what people expect to see on a
map that that kind of cream color right
anyway we have not chosen any default
style yet for
vector okay fine but we need to work on
that
and yes that's nice that that's vector i
mean it's just very uncolorful
you know only the rod cells are working
[Music]
um this needs work right and and
we should yeah
okay uh
oh okay osm renderers also approximate
building heights from number of floors
um okay all right let's keep going jose
right um okay so let's have a look at
the other things quickly so something we
are
also doing right now sorry by the way
i'm just trying to remember something
if you want to scale shown on the map if
you want a
a thing that marks 10 miles etc etc etc
there's an option for doing that right
yes exactly although it occurs to me
jose that it might need to
go vector well no i mean it is vector
i mean but it needs to probably know
what the
you know background is a bit more right
right
because it's showing up there all in
black at the moment
and that's hopeless yeah i see it but
it's hopeless hopeless
right so that's another to-do list item
but by the way
we are also running the the collision
algorithm with
the skill bar so so labels don't collide
with it
really cool right
that's nice okay but by the way i mean
so clearly
what we need to work towards and we need
to work on the design for this is for
all these different features
do you include them do you not include
them those kinds of things
right in other words you know streets
you know airports etc etc etc
i mean that's part of yeah anyway you
get it
i also think if i wanted to
label a particular road if i wanted to
highlight a particular road and label it
even if it was a small road
that's something eventually i'm going to
want to do just like in anatomy
you know you might want to label some
particular tiny anatomical feature
okay let's move on this is lovely but
let's
okay so the these other things are more
technical and these are also things we
need to
uh fix or improve for handling of
of vector primitives so should i should
i go back to my version or am i is it
all going to be broken
uh well the this part actually is it's
not even in the x candle yet
okay all right fine fine so i mean
that's why i i sent you everything
already evaluated so um
so the idea here is to have better
control
on the bounds of things so not only
faster so it's like five times faster
but also you see the difference here
this is this makes
hundreds of kilometers of of difference
right because
we are there is now some sort of
adaptive discretization where it matters
of the of the geoprimitives and this is
if i say you're saying if i say geo
bounds of a country that has squiggly
borders
that this will somehow go and figure out
as it tries to find the bound
it will try and look at the subdivided
border to find the actual
what is the north-south extent including
that little proboscis that is very thin
is that correct right so so the
i mean for countries in which our the
boundaries are already quite
well discretized i mean there are small
segments this is not going to make much
difference
but for cases in which we have a geopath
which is very long and so we
actually go and implement there some
discretization
this is going to subdivide better and
then it will be
that's nice i mean i don't know how this
works for regions because they're also
you could imagine some region that
there's some kind of julius set or
something
with some tentacle or mandelbrot set
with a tentacle hanging out
and does it how does it find that how
does it
know i think well raya can explain
better but i think with regions you have
a parameter to specify the discreteness
while in geo we do all these things
automatically and so what i'm trying to
do
is just to do better notice i mean it
depends on what kind of region you have
often we can get it exactly um
if if it's a mesh region then we have it
there's nothing more to do uh if it's
something
that's continuous and we're just now
adding bezier and b spline and stuff
um then yes it needs to uh
you know finer discretization to get it
tighter
okay all right let's keep going we've
got to rush through these
okay so then this is another important
thing which is right now there are
horrible errors and i chose especially
bad case here
and so we are moving into something
better magnificent
yeah so what about for other planets
does it correctly do the texture
well for other planets we we don't have
primitives
so we i mean we we never had this type
of problem with images
because images it's uh it's pixel it's
independent
so there is this is a problem of glob of
globality
of vector primitives right the fact that
we have to cut
and sometimes they don't cut at the
proper place etc
oh it's beautiful so antarctica
and yes so this handles all those cases
better so there's no hole at the center
of my there's no there's no cut line in
antarctica now
um
well the line of antarctica isn't the
polygon originally it's not that we cut
it so i that's a bit
more difficult to to solve i
don't have the you mean antarctica has a
branch cut effectively because of the
coordinate singularity
yes and that's in the data so we would
have to go and actually do surgery in
the data if we removed it from the data
the new algorithms would be able to
handle that we probably should do it
so it's a it's an unfortunate case i
mean arguably it should be changed in
the data i mean
where's right we can do that now with
the new
polygon because let's do it
it's embarrassing somebody's going to go
looking for the it's like
searching for the northwest passage or
something they're searching for the line
through antarctica
right we will need uh actually we will
need both versions because uh
in any way previous version of uh
warfarin language
kind of handled your polygon right
right and it's using in alpha i mean
perhaps
yeah we might need both versions
at the same time yeah fair enough okay
very well i think we should fix
antarctica before somebody searches for
the
what would it be the i don't know is it
a north south
cut i don't know where it is but anyway
okay
so convert filled objects into
geopolitics as you can see it pretty
much has to be a north south cut
yes okay fair enough
um okay so another thing uh there is
this new utility
which is able to take our current uh
object
expressed until now in with field curves
with the holes so this would be eurasia
and this is the caspian sea and this is
some
big lake in in netherlands and so
now this tool is able to take the
quarter million points
and quickly create the single geopolygon
that describes exactly the same thing
so so eventually we want to move from
this type of description to this type of
description
okay right and this is just are we
providing user level functions or wfr
functions for doing that polygon
combination um not at the moment but
these two i mean i don't think this tool
should be exposed in system but it can
be
certainly a wfr function fine let's do
it
and then finally a
another thing that i showed these to you
and some
i limiting long ago and you didn't like
the idea so it right now
is the it's an internal utility so the
idea here is that
sometimes you want things in a different
longitude determination so for example
we give russia
with longitudes between -180 180.
so this um part here
i think it's called kamchatka uh it's uh
it's on the other side so if we
this function can move any geo object to
be
in the longitude determination you want
and so you would put it there now
but now the longitudes are going from
there to that
right so geographics doesn't care
and all of the geofunctionality is able
to handle that
but sometimes if i say area for example
if i say
perimeter will come the camp chip
whatever it is peninsula
be correctly perimetered or something
in other words if i say in that first
case
um right and you say
geo area of russia
so that gives that and these one i'm
i'm not sure i have the correct branch
here sorry let's try
but i may not no sorry i don't have but
if i if i take this polygon directly
and i say the area it will give the same
okay so you're saying that this this is
merely a coordinate
a choice of coordinates this is not
exactly
it is one of these things in which users
have to sometimes
go and manually insert mods and things
like that so it
it it's just a way of simply so we
probably should package this somehow i'm
just not sure
it's not the world's most common issue
it's not i mean it appears sometimes for
example astronomers like to work from 0
to 360
and in older times they they wanted to
have negative longitudes
and so sometimes they do this
transformation so okay so
like
where you want to see the phase curves
with negative face basically and not
jump you know it has to continue i see
and so there's a special algorithm in
that plot function to
to create the continuous face
okay
[Music]
i mean this is and that's what you need
in complex analysis too
when you want the argument variation so
do we have that in the geo in the
complex
plots something analogous to that
that you slide around the phase in other
words
we don't actually maybe we should we
need that yeah
so because that's going to that's the
question of whether where the
discontinuity
in colors yeah the phases yeah
another case that appears frequently is
that you have a line that goes around
around the ear several times so it jumps
every time it goes through the data line
say so this function could have a value
here
continuous or something that the lines
and and so now you have
longitude slide orbit so what
um for example loxo drums that go around
the arrows multiple times
um let's see here what could i do geo
graphics
but if i see countries there are not so
many empires where the sun never sets
anymore
so it's like no but you can spiral
around the earth
yeah exactly so if i go let's start with
that
and i say look suture
so um sorry
let's keep our change oh
so what i mean went wrong here
20 000 what
twenty thousand miles you want oh sorry
sir
exactly this is this we want to add a
lot of zeros exactly
yes yes yes yes um i was thinking
kilometers
so let's put this as bigger angle
and this what the heck is happening so
this is this is clear there
in uh yeah so so this this is just going
around the earth it's
spiraling so what should i do here
geo projection
let's use a
lumper symmetra and
centering i'm going to choose the north
pole
i'm hoping this will be clearer
right so this is spiraling right
so if if this goes multiple times around
so
let's put here 80 and let's increase
this to 60 right
so so this is going to increase in
longitude multiple times
right so if users may have a
representation in which longitude jumps
continuously from -180 to plus 180 or
vice versa
and they may want the other one in which
longitude keeps increasing increasing
so this function i get it
so hold on so basically
this is a normalization like a mod type
normalization
in this coordinate system but it's
analogous to what we'd have to do in the
complex
in the it's a little bit different
because this is taking this data
i suspect that we want and we're not
going to figure it out right now
we want an option for these geo things
it feels a bit like geo variant
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah i wanted a solution coordinate
system right
we need something that doesn't have to
be inserted into everything
no i understand
so basically it's a geo coordinate
system or something
you're saying or geo longitude because
it's only affected
does it only affect longitude or could
you do it with latitude as well
latitude is not periodic so there is no
need for this in latitude
okay so it's only longitude but my point
is that if you have
a list of objects and there are geodiscs
for example with the center
etc you want to change all of them at
once no i understand that
so i mean it's basically geolongitude
system
arrow something or other
separate discussion let's have that a
separate meeting okay
and and that's a couple of comments and
questions on live stream
um
okay it's a comment about fortunately
countries don't have fractal borders
otherwise it would uh
be expensive to put border fences and
things
yeah well i mean most countries the
borders are defined by contracts
basically they're defined by
you know like surveyor type things you
know this distance from this river to
this thing to that thing
and so on it's an interesting use case
for computational contracts
to be able to take that specification
and actually convert it to
points on the earth um
comment about posting material before
these meetings good luck
i suspect it's not these meetings are a
real time
um comment from takashwar
about uh consonants okay so this is so
something we have not
which which i hope is coming francisco
is historical country borders which we
obviously have the data for
and that's something that now we are in
a position to actually put in here like
to say dated
you know france comma 1650 or something
is that correct yes we have the
historical countries but i i i think the
question is more about the continents
so that's like that i know i understand
i'm asking a question here
the historical countries when will we be
able to say
dated of france comma 1650 and have it
render
in this whole geographic system is that
really working
yes i think that it works
the roman empire or something let's
play dangerously and see if we have data
for france in
what yeah i don't know
um i'm not sure we have france for that
year
okay okay there was no france but but
yes
okay right try try eighteen
something or yes um after the french
revolution or something i don't know
1850 try 1850
no why is this not working
i'm not sure if it's working well maybe
you need the historical country of
france oh yes yes yes exactly
so but yes we were hooking up them to
also the countries
so let's go to a roman empire
well in 1850 good luck exactly um
so let's say yeah minus 100
yeah okay
okay okay magnificent but that's now the
old okay so but with vector maps you'll
be able to do this as well right
uh yeah yeah the vector maps just
affects the background
exactly okay so the polygon is a vector
thing anyway
right classic
he doesn't like classic
okay so what can we use here that's nice
but but so so now what if i want the
labeling based on
ancient rome
[Laughter]
what's that do we have any of that data
do we have the steady data
no no we don't have historical city yet
yeah
we looked we looked at that a number of
years ago we looked at getting that
right
yes what we added at some point was uh
founding uh so dates of when this city
was set
etc right but that doesn't tell us that
you know
carthage for example will not appear
because it disappeared so to speak
right yes we could try to filter which
cities that are currently now
where that exists today existed sometime
in the past
even though constantinople changed its
name and things like that
um right i mean the bigger issue is you
like zoom in and you're gonna start
getting modern roads
with
yeah i mean there is a data i know
christopher has data on roman roads
we we should at some point make this
actually work
um now the question is consonants we
have the data in wolf and alpha on
consonants right
do we have it here if you say minus 100
million
years i don't think we have it yet
no we have the ability i mean we have
the polygons in some
paclet uh in geographics we have some
examples of that
what could it be um
yes we have some some geological times
yeah here
so if we don't load ex specifically
the polygon then it does work
okay but it'll be nice to get that to
work in general
so you mean as another background right
yeah i don't think so yeah but i mean i
think
look if we get that and somebody asks
for dated minus 100 million years
okay it's a question from dan here
or dane um about your timing how do you
get that little timing footer
in the notebook this one yeah
i it's some uh optional inspector
yeah okay all right okay so it's
something in the option inspector um the
the
option name is evaluation completion
actions and you set it to like
show timing or timing or something
that's nice um okay somebody was asking
tarkishwa was asking if you can
convert from wgs84 to wgs72
absolutely we can do all of those lovely
geodetic
computations how do you do how do you do
that conversion
it's a geo so before moving there is
also now this
nice thing which i use quite a lot you
just do that and now every
operation will be timed oh i see it's
quite useful that is nice is it
documented in echo timing
yes it is okay wait
and now it's not okay all right we
should wrap this up okay one more thing
here
uh yes you were asking about datum
conversions
yeah so yeah so so it's possible to say
i don't know lat lawn or 40
30 40
here we say wsg 72 or something like
that
and then this will change to some other
one to your position
w right
wgs34 probably i want to see how
different they are
not no not much
so we need to have the data and we don't
have it for all of them sorry
it's what do you mean sorry let's see
yes sorry yes so
there are several wsgs 84s so we need to
say which one
and so you it you see it changes a
little bit oh this is an interesting
thing sir jari is commenting
that um the border survey
russia finland border survey 7000 pages
long
that apparently its coordinates are
defined on coordinates tied to the
eurasian continental plate
that is an interesting problem happened
to a friend of mine many years ago
bought a
bought a house which was across the san
andreas fault and an earthquake happened
and the
the lot changed size and shape
um right so this is the question of
datums that change with time which is
becoming very important for example for
for australia they have a datum from 20
years ago and it has changed like two
meters
and so they are working on the
conversion plate motion or what plate
motion plate motion around
australia is like 70 centimeters per
year
i have no idea is where they're going
uh there are maps i think it's going
north
north east but there are maps of the of
the
change yes no idea and so they are
working
and the us is also working on new dayton
the north american dayton
2020 was called but i think it's delayed
a few years
i see i see all these new datums change
with time
because of plate tectonics right
um interesting okay all right
we should wrap this meeting up oh yeah i
was prepared here just in case you
wanted an example of this so this is an
example
of of oh spectacular of the speed app or
for multiplication of
a thousand numbers spectacular
question is the support for a round
in um uh
you know in broader support in the
system for a round
well i think once it behaves
much better in this direction then it
will be easier to support in other
places
okay do we have a map of where it needs
to be supported
not yet but we should construct it
right that's a good lcc project um
[Music]
oh that's funny sanders commenting geo
distance of dated sydney comma 2020
comma sydney does that work
goodness uh let's see
it's not going to work yet no no no but
but we
we want to add a date dated support to
your distance and
such functions eventually so yeah oh
that's right
2020 sorry yes yes i was thinking of
something in the past
right no no there is no we don't have
the information for that future datum
yet yes
right sounds good okay terrific stuff
thanks a lot
um thanks to folks on the live stream um
okay ethan is commenting many caribbean
islands are moving quickly towards
africa
interesting the um all right okay
we'll see y'all later and for folks who
are following our live streams we have
another live stream at the top of the
next hour
talk to your lot of the same people